[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on se retrouve ici à lignières pour
cette page économique on est avec vous
patricia pérochon vous êtes la pdg
directrice générale la grippe
c'est la plus ancienne marque
constructeur de tracteurs made in france
et il y tout a commencé en 1930
expliquez moi oui donc ça a commencé en
1930 avec monsieur maurice duprat qui a
conçu café a conçu le premier tracteur
agricole 1,93 directrice et une avance
sur mondial à l'époque il n'a pas eu
conscience et de cette marque française
de tracteurs agricoles avec cette
conception là il a était il là et s'est
orienté sur deux activités principales
le tracteur forestier et il a apporté au
territoire un outil de travail pour tous
les débardeurs parce qu'il n'avait que
les mulets les chevaux à l'époque donc
il a permis d'industrialiser ce monde
très fermé du forestier est la deuxième
activité qu'il a prise aussi c'est que
il a participé à la construction de tout
le réseau électrique en construisant
grâce à cette technologie de quatre
roues motrices les premières forces pose
poteaux pour le réseau français
électriques et les tireurs de lignes à
haute tension
les engins industriels voilà les indiens
industriels liés sur le réseau qui sont
toujours d'actu en activité et alors il
a repris cette entreprise en 1930 la
marque a été déposée qu'en 1992
oh oui et c'est parce qu'il l'avait
jamais déposé en fait il n'avait jamais
déposé la marque et heureusement on a pu
l'art déposé pour la sauver parce qu'il
faut savoir que pour la marque agricole
agrippe donc c'est la dernière marque
française de constructeur de tracteurs
agricoles et sur les 50 qu'il y avait
dans les trente glorieuses et je trouve
ça le constat complètement lamentable et
c'est pour ça qu'on s'acharne autant à
sauver ce patrimoine industriel français
est d'autant plus à lignières comment ça
se fait justement vous êtes vous êtes le
dernier c'est un patrimoine qui se perd
un peu avec l'annoncé qu'il ya plus de
constructeurs français tracteurs
agricoles donc nous d'un aparté on
souhaiterait relancer le petit writer 4
motrices vintage électrique mais
priorité et en ou deux plutôt d'essayer
de survivre avec le marasme économique
qui actuellement est donc on a en a
lancé depuis cinq ans la reprise du
tracteur forestier
donc il ya des innovations majeures qui
ont été faites pour relancer cette
fabrication
on est devant un tracteur que vous avez
amené à l'elysée l'année dernière
raconte et moi on a eu la chance d'être
sélectionnés au niveau du département
pour représenter le département à
l'elysée dans le savoir-faire français
dû fabriquer made in france
donc c'était un petit peu angoissant
parce que amener un tracteur de 14
tonnes à l'elysée et surtout faire
rentrer dans le jardin d'un jardin allez
y si justement on les neuf et on répare
on est allé voir comment comment on
travaille vos salariés voyez ce
reportage réalisé avec coralie pierre et
laurent blanc ce sont les tout premiers
tracteurs agrippant donc ses détracteurs
quatre roues motrices directrice à pont
suspendu
c'est avec ces deux engins que la
ventura grippe a commencé il y à plus de
90 ans à grippe c'est d'abord l'histoire
d'un homme maurice duprat le fondateur
de l'entreprise dans
l'entre-deux-guerres jusqu'à 95
personnes ont travaillé ici dans cet
atelier historique
c'est vraiment un patrimoine industriel
et on essaye de faire la continuité à ce
cette marque et à maurice duprat qui est
le le
le précurseur de la mécanisation
forestière l'entreprise a ensuite connu
des heures plus sombres sur le plan
économique le nombre de salariés a
aujourd'hui considérablement baissé elle
consacre désormais 70% de son activité à
la rénovation des tireurs de lignes de
haute tension et des tracteurs
forestiers
le reste de l'activité comprend des
pièces détachées et de la maintenance
j'aime bien je m'étais jamais ce qu'on
fait et puis justement il ya le avec le
nouveau projet de ressortir des
nouvelles machines et où c'est
intéressant ça permet de aussi des
d'évoluer nous mêmes pauvres trop
d'ailleurs technologie ressortir de
nouvelles machines comme le tracteur
agricole vintage mais en version
électrique et pérenniser l'activité
c'est le souhait de l'entreprise ligne
airoise qui rêvent d'un soutien
financier pour que ce savoir faire
industriels puissent perdurer
on est toujours avec vous patricia
pérochon alors on vient de voir votre
activité dans l' usine
malheureusement la crise fait que vous
traversez quelques difficultés
économiques
c'est ça oui tout à fait parce que ben
comme beaucoup d'autres activités on a
des difficultés actuellement le chiffre
d'affaires a bien diminué et on a eu des
reports de deux chantiers importants
pour la rénovation des tireurs de ligne
pour le rte
suite à la crise sanitaire qui nous ont
fragilisés parce que notre activité
principale étant la maintenance le
projet pour lancer l'entreprise sur la
partie reconstruction avec toutes les
innovations qui ont été apportées à
elles se sont trouvées freiner et
maintenant eh ben on peut plus faire
face aux investissements parce que j'ai
pas le retour de toutes les
la production qui devait en découler
hélas là vous recherchez les personnes
qui peuvent vous aider des mécènes si
oui voilà parce que on a tellement à
coeur de sauver cette dernière marque
qui plus anciennes marques françaises
que on est prêts près du but et on se
retrouve fragilisée là c'est pas c'est
c'est douloureux mais on est en
redressement judiciaire
ben on a des espoirs de perdurer mais
sans une main tendue ou un mécène ou
d'aider des institutions publiques qui
nous met en en entreprise pouvant avec
un savoir-faire qui sont stratégiques
pour le tireur de ligne et bien
malheureusement il y aura plus de
marques agrippe si on n'arrive pas à
franchir l'étape et et bombe à la crise
a fait que qu'empirer notre agilité et
ont certains industriels pouvant nous
accompagner ou des mécènes qui peuvent
sauvegarder cette ancienne marque
française parce que c'est il ya vraiment
beaucoup de choses on a tellement fait
et ça une aura internationale
l'importance de sauver le patrimoine
industriel français merci patricia
prochaine avoir été à notre indiqué
merci d'être notre et quotas merci à
tous